the less defund the police nonsense is
still wreaking havoc on Democrat cities
this time as massive mob about 100
people ransacking a Los Angeles area gas
station acting like they own the place
and helping themselves to thousands of
dollars worth of alcohol and snacks
police said they couldn't intervene
because they were outnumbered I'm sure
radical district attorney George gascon
will let them off with a warning and in
nearby Los Angeles newly elected
left-wing mayor Karen bass is desperate
to add new officers to the force after
losing over a thousand to resignations
and retirements
my number one job as mayor is to keep
Angelino safe
but unfortunately the reality is is that
lap
is down hundreds of officers this has
been an ongoing Trend in LA and in
cities across the country and so I'm
concerned that the Department's recent
release of information will cause even
more officers to leave my budget
proposal calls for Urgent action to hire
hundreds of officers next year on the
way to restoring the department to full
strength
judge I want to know what you think
about this well you know it really it it
it's very interesting she wants to
replace I think it's like a thousand are
gone with you know hundreds of officers
you can replace them but when you've got
kids in gangs of 500 or more and a
police department that has been beaten
down demeaned and their arrests are not
being supported where the kids are going
in or the defendants or suspects are
going in and then being released within
a minute I mean you've got law
enforcement that is totally demoralized
they've been beaten down to the point
where they're not even making arrests
plus they're being outnumbered look at
this I mean I've heard all day about
cases in in Compton and Los Angeles
where police haven't gotten involved
because there's only two or three of
them with a gang like this let me tell
you what the problem really is it
started in 2015 you remember the Freddie
gray Freddie gray case where you had the
mayor saying something like you know you
got to give them you got to give them a
little breath so they can you know they
can do what they need to do it's
something like we gave those who wish to
destroy space to destroy so Baltimore
burned it was looted there were
businesses destroyed and then the
Chicago mayor yesterday who says you
know these Mass protests I mean they're
just teens rioting protesting poverty
and segregation that was a Senator and
then you've got everyone kind of
apologizing for these kids and so we're
never going to end any of this
destruction and take down as long as the
laws that are in place stay in place
you've got police who are not
incentivized to make an arrest a
criminal justice system that is
incentivized and required by law to
release the accused and it happens every
weekend and nobody's getting upset about
it and so it's not going to change I'm
telling you it's not going to change you
know Dana you look at the mayor that was
just elected in Chicago and he says you
got to let these kids breathe a little
you got to give them a safe place to go
be crazy I guess and then now Karen bass
is in LA and she's saying no we need
more police officers is she at least
saying the right thing well
yeah what I mean I think she's saying
the obvious which they obviously need
more police officers so if you lose a
thousand police officers it's not like
you just lost all the rookies you lost
all that experience which means then you
don't have all of those experienced
officers in order to train that's the
same in the military right like if you
you need to have people who have
longevity with the organization and the
institution in order to make sure that
the good practices are passed down and I
also felt like in her
comments maybe she's if you read the
words on paper it would be one thing but
listening to her it was like she was
reading A Mother's Day Proclamation
where's the concern like I I believe in
communication talking about persuasion
you have to meet people where they are
in terms of your level of concern and
your tone so where's the conviction
where's the passion she I I think that
she recognizes she's
caught the car and now she doesn't know
what to do necessarily because where are
you going to find those officers if the
other thing is nobody's talking about
the worker the worker at that gas
station he hit him he hid in the
bathroom yeah while this was happening
and then he comes out and he finds okay
everything's destroyed and there's no
consequences so what happened to the
Democrats is that in terms of the
working people's party right
who's going to want to go to work if you
can do this and have no consequences
Greg what Dana's talking about
accountability uh why what are a
thousand more police officers going to
do if all they can do is stand there and
watch it happen yeah we said this
yesterday that the I the irony is if you
tell a group of people that they can't
have anything in life that means they
can do whatever they want yeah so there
are no consequences and no
accountability uh why you know an
example is we're they they use the
phrase street takeovers they're seeing
these Street takeovers why because
Buddha Jed says
streets are racist so by propagating
this ideology of of losers that you have
to look back and everything you see is
bad grocery stores are racist white
people inside them are racist traffic
laws are racist police dogs are racists
roads are racist
um then basically it all adds up into a
into a society that has it coming and
this isn't something new if you remember
um uh during the riots there were a lot
of liberals and I think magazines like
new in uh in like New York Magazine and
others that were saying that looting the
Looting was justified that is how they
get their Justice in a world that's
racist so what happens is all what you
have are these groups are doing things
and they don't care about the
consequences because their life's
already screwed meanwhile Society
majority of society want black and brown
people to achieve their biggest dreams
because that helps everybody we want
everybody to be happy the the side that
keeps saying that your life sucks
because it's irrevocably racist they're
destroying those lives what you're
seeing is the product of a poisonous
toxic left-wing ideology I don't want
Alabama fans to be happy just but Harold
this is much the softball as I can give
you we talk about the south South La
Watts Compton we talk about south side
of Chicago uh East New York are there
just certain areas in these big cities
that no matter what the politics do
they're just always going to have
trouble with things like this I like
tough questions so um say two things
first
um we need probably two to three
thousand more officers in Los Angeles
Los Angeles and Greg has a better
perspective on this and those you look
at the big cities in the country the
geography of Los Angeles is just
different than a Chicago or Dallas or
New York it's just bigger so you may
need this is no excuse for this don't
get me wrong I think I agree with a lot
and you can say what you guys want to
say about me agreeing I agree with what
you're saying about how we have we have
set up we've put a set of expectations
on a lot of these kids I remember if you
were ever doing a thing wrong you would
never want to film it they were filming
yes what they were doing which is an
amazing and astonishing thing to me I
hope that and I said this yesterday on
Dana's show I hope that the committee
that's here in New York that was here
yesterday to just share a committee I
hope they travel to Los Angeles in San
Francisco and Chicago and I hope as a
part of what they're doing I think it's
there's politics involved with
everything but two things can be right
there's a crime problem and there's
there's politics I hope as they do these
things and they highlight some of the
shortcomings of what the politicians and
the politics in those areas are doing
that they perhaps offer some some
answers it might be great if you told
the city of Los Angeles I make this up
they need two thousand or you need three
thousand new officers we'll give you the
resources for it but you've got to
change this to get it because if indeed
the mayor is right about wanting 400 to
500 officers she probably needs more
your honor let her understand how this
is what we will do to help you I listen
to speaker McCarthy here in New York
yesterday he laid out a list of things
he would do to raise a debt selling they
should do that with crime and other
things as well because if you think
about Public Safety you sit and be a
political issue it used to be an issue
it was an issue before where Democrats
and Republicans we all agree on what was
right and wrong and what I just saw
there happen in Compton that was wrong
yeah your parents should be telling you
that's wrong and if you are going to do
that your parents should at least tell
you don't film it
can I say one thing there was a change
between 22 and 23 in Compton uh crime
going up 81 percent
that is a signal to the rest of us that
when we're not arresting more of them
are going to come out and commit crimes
it's real easy Compton's had a crime
problem for a long time though worse
than ever now great music we have to go
on this I hope that Compton solves this
crime problem I hope that America finds
a better place with this all right up
next the shocking influence of China I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now